it's the morning of September 1st 2022
and the multi-millionaire chairman of
Russia's largest private oil company is
about to die his name is ravil maganov
and he just had a heart attack ravil was
rushed to what's known as the Kremlin
Clinic a hospital where all of Russia's
Elite go to get treated but the heart
attack wouldn't be what killed him no
after maganov recovered from the heart
attack he somehow fell out of his
Hospital window down six stories to his
death in broad daylight
police say they are investigating the
death as a suicide others speculate that
maganov must have plunged to his death
after trying to smoke a cigarette out
the window because people definitely
accidentally fall out of Hospital
Windows all the time what's strange is
that his massive Oil Company Luke oil
put out an official statement after he
died and in that state
Lukoil said that he died not from
falling out of a window but from quote
severe illness and quote I guess falling
out a window is now considered a severe
illness
what's even stranger is that the death
of reveal maganov is far from the first
time a powerful Russian oligarch has
died this year reveal maganov marks the
eighth Russian oligarch to have died a
suspicious death since the start of this
year the same year that Russia decided
to invade Ukraine
someone is cleaning house in the Russian
oligarchy the bodies are stacking up but
why
stay dangerous and let's get into it
foreign
all these Russian oligarchs Rose to
power and Fell From Grace because of one
thing human nature everything you want
someone else has in their hands so if
you want to move up in the world you
have to understand human nature this is
hands down the most important skill you
need to know and that's why you gotta
check out this incredible audiobook
called the laws of human nature by one
of my favorite authors Robert Greene in
it Robert Greene looks at the most
important figures in history from
Pericles to Queen Elizabeth the first to
Martin Luther King Jr to see how they
apply the laws of human nature to get
what they wanted and the best part is
that you can listen to the laws of human
nature for free right now when you sign
up for audible with the link below I've
been using Audible for the past four
years and it's completely changed my
life for the better well audible you can
listen to life-changing audiobooks while
you're commuting cleaning or doing
chores so it's way more convenient than
books and if the loss of human nature
doesn't interest you that is okay
because you can choose any title you
want and I guarantee you there's an
audiobook on Audible right now that is
the perfect fit for you so what are you
waiting for get a free audiobook when
you sign for a free 30-day trial with
the link below and if you're an Amazon
Prime member you'll actually get two
free titles instead of one so pause the
video and get 30 days of audible for
free by going to audible.com Jake Trent
or texting Jake Trent to 500 500 that's
audible.com with the link below or text
Jake Trent to 500 500 thanks to Audible
for sponsoring this video
the Ukraine invasion
[Music]
invade Target Leonid Shulman
Leonard Shulman was one of the highest
ranking Executives at gazprom the most
important natural gas company in Russia
they're the only ones allowed to sell
gas to foreign countries and they're the
company behind the nordstream one
pipeline that just shut off gas to
Europe
needless to say gazprom is a very
valuable geopolitical weapon to the
Kremlin
and this high-ranking gas prom executive
was found lying on his bathroom floor
with multiple stab wounds sources say
the knife was found in the bathtub far
away from shulman's reach conveniently
there was a suicide note so obviously
shulman's death was ruled as a suicide
because you were to kill yourself you
would definitely write a suicide note
and then proceed to stab yourself
multiple times in the bathroom and then
throw the knife into the bathtub before
collapsing on the ground to bleed out
one day after Russia invaded Ukraine
another top executive from gazprom was
found dead in the same gated Housing
Development that Shulman just died in
the body of Alexander tayulikov was
found hanging by his partner in his
garage on February 25th according to
reports he had been badly beaten before
his death but according to Russian
newspapers it was just another suicide
few days later Mikhail Watford was next
and he was also discovered hanging in
his multi-million dollar home in Surrey
England people close to him refused to
believe he had killed himself his
neighbor even claimed that Watford said
he was on Putin's Hit List she continued
to say quote I find it hard to believe
that Misha Watford would have taken his
own life it doesn't add up end quote
these deaths have now gone International
and it was just getting started
April 18 2022 one month later 26 year
old Anastasia avayev couldn't get a hold
of her family her father vladislav of
ayev was the former vice president of
Russia's third largest bank what bank is
that gas prom bank which is owned by
none other than gazprom so when his
daughter couldn't get a hold of them she
decided to check in on them at their
multi-million dollar apartment in Moscow
she makes her way to their apartment
opens the door and what she sees will
forever scar her for life
her younger 13 year old sister Maria
laid slumped on the floor her body was
pierced with gunshot wounds blood was
everywhere her pregnant mother was the
same story dead on the floor from bullet
wounds her unborn child still in her
womb and her dad the banker was also
found dead pistol in hand and surprise
surprise the Russian media immediately
said it was a murder-suicide that
vladislav avayev shot his family before
shooting himself
quote perhaps this was because of the
sanctions everyone is depressed some are
willing to go to Extreme Measures end
quote one of the neighbors suggested
latislavaiev was also very close with
Vladimir Putin
if this was a one-off case it might well
be a murder-suicide but then less than a
day later it happened again two thousand
miles away in Spain Russian gas oligarch
Sergey protosena and most of his family
are enjoying a spring holiday at their
Villa in Spain the family's son Fedor
decided to stay in France instead Fedor
had been trying to get in contact with
his family for a while with no luck he
started getting worried so he contacted
the local authorities to check up on
them the Spanish police arrived at the
Mansion at 4 pm less than one day after
the Avaya family was brutally murdered
and the discovery they made was even
more gruesome sergey's wife and daughter
were axed to death in their sleep while
the father Sergey was found hanging
outside the Villa suspiciously there
were no fingerprints on the weapons no
blood stains on his body after he
supposedly hacked his family to death as
he
previous record of domestic violence or
abuse once again the patriarch of the
family was immediately suspected of
murdering his family and then killing
himself after his death novitec the
company where protocenia worked for
almost 20 years had this to say quote
unfortunately speculations have emerged
in the media about this topic but we are
convinced that these speculations bear
no relation to reality end quote the sun
Fedor protocenia strongly denies that
his dad did this both these oligarchs
were worth more than 400 million dollars
each both these oligarchs were
powerhouses in Russia's upper class
both them and their families died of
violent death within less than a day of
each other
well another day in Russia another
mysterious death of someone who spoke
out against Putin's War for all we know
is that two former Russian gas
Executives and members of their families
died in two separate countries within 24
hours
there were at least three more deaths
that followed Andre Krakowski the
manager of one of the most famous ski
resorts in Sochi Russia which also just
happened to be owned by none other than
gasprom he fell off a cliff while on a
hike Alexander subatin a billionaire and
a former executive at Luke oil who
somehow how wound up dead after going to
see a shaman to relieve hangover
symptoms and then Dan Rappaport a
latvian-born finance guy who had worked
in Moscow he fell from his luxury
apartment in Washington DC Dan's body
was found with orange flip-flops a black
hat a Florida driver's license and over
two thousand five hundred dollars in
cash
the only question left is why
but before we reveal that if you enjoy
controversial videos like this we have
even more documentaries that are too
controversial to be ever released to the
public like our private documentary on
the cia's torture program where they
arrested a bunch of suspects during the
war on terror shipped them off to Black
sites all over the world and then
straight up tortured them with the most
deranged cruel enhanced interrogation
techniques that they could come up with
it gets really dark the things that
those CIA agents did might be more
disturbing than anything we've ever
covered on this channel before needless
to say this video would not get
monetized if we published it publicly so
it's only available to members of this
Channel and you can watch it right now
by scrolling down and hitting that join
button below we put out a private
documentary every single month going
over everything they're too afraid to
teach you in school for only five
dollars a month and there's a refund
policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund scroll down
right now and click that join button now
back to the video
[Music]
[Music]
in late 2021 Putin Was preparing to
invade Ukraine and an invasion of this
scale requires a lot of money you have
to pay for weapons equipment soldiers
salaries Logistics food the list goes on
so what Putin does is he finances these
operations through what do you know gas
prom and gasprom Bank who many of the
men we just went over are associated
with that means the executives there
knew all about this secret War financing
after all the gas sector is the most
corrupt sector in Russia but some of
these oligarchs didn't want Putin to
invade so it's suspected that some of
them started leaking information about
Putin's secret financing the Kremlin
caught wind of this so Russian
intelligence Drew up two lists
these two lists contain the names of the
suspected moles in Russia's energy
industry quote the list was presented to
Putin by the FSB the Federal Security
Service and Putin approved the
liquidation of everyone on the list
without even looking at it end quote
this is according to Anders aslund
author of Russia's crony capitalism and
a Swedish Economist who told the New
York Post about all of this
from that point on the liquidation began
you guys knew we had to make a video on
this so knowing what you know now would
you want to be a billionaire if you made
your money in Russia I for one enjoy my
life so no but let me know if you would
take the chance in the comments below
but thank you so much for watching this
video if you're new here this is one of
the biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime that you can understand how this
world Works instead of becoming a victim
to it so if you enjoyed this one we have
multiple videos just like this coming
out every single week for free so click
on subscribe button below but that's
going to wrap it up you can follow me on
Instagram Jake Tran thanks for being
part of the watch.n club as always stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you